j'ai jamais fait de mal à la maison
parce que je te crois tout à fait
et tu vois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah on va parler en Pologne est-ce que
vous avez vu ça une streameuse qui
conduisait avec son téléphone et elle a
écrasé un chien qui passe à proximité il
est en train de se filmer en direct au
volant de sa voiture au moment de la
scène et la vidéo était divisée en live
en fait et c'est le pire c'est qu'elle a
ensuite mis la responsabilité sur les
maîtres du chien regardez
[Musique]
à 100 % parce qu'elle se filme en plus
elle regarde son téléphone au moment de
l'accident mais elle trouve quand même
le moyen d'accuser les maîtres du chien
la dit c'est de leur faute et qu'il
fallait qu'il surveille leur chien et le
pire dans tout ça c'est qu'elle laisse
filmer ça qu'une fois qu'elle a écrasé
le chien elle laisse la vidéo en live
comme si c'était un spectacle j'espère
qu'elle sera sanctionnée et c'est
vraiment c'est horrible
à ce moment-là
ça reste quand même les réseaux sociaux
et ça pue le fait qu'à 1000%
[Musique]
est une véritable star des réseaux
sociaux suivi par plus d'un million
d'abonnés l'influenceuse aurait été
placée en garde à vue pour des faits de
maltraitance sur l'un de ses enfants
ces trois lettres un beau pardon ah je
t'écrase la main que de voir ses parents
faire l'amour et les deux amoureux
affirment aujourd'hui que leurs enfants
ont été auditionnés par la police le 15
février dernier après des signalements
anonymes pour des faits de maltraitance
voilà là
donc il se passe rien c'est quoi alors
[Musique]
indépendante de ma volonté que
j'expliquerai alors il y a aucune
maltraitance envers mes bébés et ça ne
t'inquiète pas que le comment dire les
professionnels l'ont bien relevé
d'accord les raisons sociaux ont eu un
énorme impact et une énorme importance
dans cette affaire donc je m'exprimer
une très mauvaise importance dans le
tête à faire voilà les réseaux sociaux
font 90% responsables de ce qui est en
train de se passer donc pour te glisser
dans le contexte de toute façon j'allais
venir après toute cette histoire quand
tout sera réglé et apaisé m'exprimer
m'exprimer et
lisser cette affreuse image qu'on m'a
collé je suis pas une maman parfaite
mais j'ai toujours tout fait pour mes
enfants j'étais tout ce que j'ai fait
tout tout a été pour eux et uniquement
pour eux dans leur intérêt j'ai jamais
j'ai fait de mal à la maison je te crois
tout à fait
alors nous et ce soir et ce soir ma
poupette nous on t'aime beaucoup tu es
venu ici on n'est pas des mecs qui
allons trahir tout ça
[Musique]
on en doute pas un instant
ils sont ils ont tout ils ont confondus
ils ont tout ils ont les vaccins à jour
ils ont tout ils ont tout l'amour ils
ont ils ont juste l'amour de leurs deux
parents tout ce qui a été contre moi a
été sorti hors contexte c'est juste
c'est juste dramatique
mais je sais mais je le pense vraiment
moi aussi je pense que c'est
je voulais pas que ça se passe comme ça
donc je voulais pas qu'on me force à le
faire là mais il y a un business du
voyeurisme qui me semble-t-il va être
dramatique c'est à dire que je pense que
ça va rendre des gens tarés mais
vraiment taré graves on va arriver à des
faits divers il y a Sylvie qui me dit
Sylvie qui me dit même dire pardon tu
vas à l'hosto et pas tu fais une vidéo
non qu'est-ce que tu lui réponds mais
oui
mais le problème c'est sa vie oui mais
est-ce que c'est la vie de ses enfants
en fait c'est à dire que je trouve que
pardonnez-moi je trouve que toutes ces
familles c'est maman ont une
responsabilité c'est-à-dire qu'elle
jette dans la lumière leurs enfants
demande pas les enfants c'est pas des
objets c'est pas des bibelots c'est pas
des codes promo donc en fait les enfants
sont jetés en peinture comme ça et après
les enfants démerdez-vous ils vont
devenir quoi ces enfants dans 10 ans
ce qui est vrai ce qui est sûr c'est la
première partie c'est l'accident
c'est l'hospitalisation c'est les
victimes samedi
un homme de 28 ans
appelle alors il appelle pas le service
de police qui est en charge de l'enquête
il fait le 17 d'accord et là il
s'explique au téléphone il dit je suis
un ami ou un ancien ami il est pas si
ancien que ça parce qu'ils sont vu le 14
janvier
je suis un ami de Pierre Palmade j'ai
des révélations à faire il détient des
vidéos
pédo pornographiques et il aurait
enfin il se vante en tout cas il dit
qu'il a eu des relations avec des
enfants qui avaient des enfants un
enfant de 7 ans et un enfant de 9 ans à
cette disposition et il lui aurait
montré sur son téléphone portable le
début d'un film pédopornographique le
parquet de Paris
ouvre immédiatement une information en
urgence saisi la brigade de protection
des mineurs et ils vont aller faire une
perquisition au domicile parisien de
Pierre Palmade travailler dans le
troisième arrondissement et là ils vont
saisir tout ce qui est disque dur
ordinateur et la vidéo aurait été
envoyée à certaines rédactions
absolument alors exactement cette
histoire alors effectivement dès le
début l'homme a dit
je ne suis pas seul il y aurait un autre
homme qui est aujourd'hui ce serait
manifesté également et certains médias
donc un média dont on n'a pas le nom là
ce soir à cette heure-là aurait eu cette
vidéo pour le moment il y a pas de
charge retenu il y a une enquête et il
est très possible il est même probable
que Pierre Palmade soit entendu très
bientôt pour cette affaire l'image la
plus récente d'un Pierre Palmade dans la
tourmente vendredi soir c'est par une
porte dérobée qui les sorties du
tribunal de Melun mis en examen pour
homicide et blessures involontaires
aggravées par l'usage de stupéfiants
quelqu'un qui l'emmène non mais il est
pas en détention
il est où la pierre Palmade alors c'est
quoi l'histoire Palmade il est dans un
hôpital à Villejuif
et qui va direct au contrôle du désert
le parquet de Melun souhaite qu'il soit
incarcéré donc on verra bien
ce que dira son avocat ce que dira le
JLD et quel sera la décision comme je
l'ai dit je suis même pas sûr que mon
client ait eu conscience qu'il y avait
un accident il a pas fuir ses
responsabilités et non sur le moment il
n'a absolument pas vu qu'il y avait eu
un accident
de l'avocate les mots me manquent pour
les commentaires ils ont réussi à partir
ils étaient quand même très structurés
et ils ont réussi à retrouver la maison
de de Pierre Palmade ils ont ramassé
leurs affaires ils ont appelé un taxi
sur le compte de Pierre Palmade donc ils
sont pas totalement désorientés
et dire nier les vidence et dire que on
n'a pas remarqué qu'il y avait un
accident j'ai envie de vous dire que
c'est un petit peu ce foot de la gueule
du monde on oublie un léger détail c'est
le deuxième a été condamné à un an de
prison avec sursis probatoire il ne
devait pas parmi ses contraintes rendre
entrer en contact avec Pierre Palmade on
le retrouve dans la voiture et on le
lâche dans la nature on marche sur la
tête est-ce qu'ils étaient vraiment
trois ou quatre c'est pas que les deux
fuyards
il n'était pas lui hein tu es
tranquillement la rédaction du nouveau
détective
et Pierre Palmas
plusieurs couilles dans le potage
est-ce que ce serait plutôt pas un
potage aux couilles
si d'être là vous avez donc été victime
de ce qu'on appelle une arnaque
sentimentale c'est rencontré sur les
réseaux sociaux il est à venir vers moi
il m'a approché il m'a envoyé un message
et puis on a commencé à échanger voilà
par par message et c'est voilà présenté
comme un entrepreneur qui travaillait
dans l'or et les diamants
voilà on a passé un bon moment et puis
très rapidement suite à ce rendez-vous
expliquer qu'il voulait quelque chose de
sérieux avec moi qui voulait s'engager
dans une relation exclusive très
rapidement j'ai vu des signaux d'alerte
c'est à dire j'ai vu voilà j'ai
découvert il y avait beaucoup d'argent
en liquide des faux papiers des chèques
en blanc qui n'étaient pas à son nom
il y avait deux cartes d'identité avec
sa photo dessus mais avec des noms
différents
je sais plus voilà il y avait une
dispute et puis encore une fois c'était
de ma faute donc il fallait que je me
fasse pardonner pour me faire pardonner
il fallait que du coup je m'investre
mon engagement et pour le premier mon
engagement il fallait du coup que je
m'investisse dans l'achat d'un acteur
d'emprise de manière comme tu avais
envie de remarqué quelqu'un tu t'es bon
ça je vais laisser sa chance aux
produits à ce moment-là au même moment
en fait je les avais une carte bancaire
que je retrouvais plus j'ai trouvé plus
chez moi
bizarre
et puis je viens voilà checker ce compte
que je sur lequel je ne vais jamais et
je vois qu'il y a des prélèvements qui
ont été faits qui ont été faits dans des
commerces qui sont aux alentours de où
il habite et il y a un prélèvement aussi
sur une société à son nom donc je fais
facilement la relation entre les
événements et je comprends que c'est un
escroc alors tu te rends vite compte
qu'en fait tu es pas la seule victime
oui effectivement parce que du coup je
commençais un petit peu à en parler sur
mes réseaux sociaux et puis notamment un
Tik Tok et je me rends compte que ce Tik
Tok fait beaucoup de vues et que dans
les commentaires il y a des centaines de
victimes en fait il y a un quart série
mais alors il a pas été mis sous écrou
par rapport aux arnaques mais par
rapport à une autre affaire avec une de
ses
ex-compagnes du coup
pour qu'il y a eu du Revenge porn et
voilà
on a perdu combien toi au total alors
moi il a volé ma carte et il ne pouvait
faire que des paiements sans contact
donc voilà c'était un montant que ça
allait du 200 300 euros il a pas pu
aller très loin les autres victimes elle
me raconte
voilà des situations qui sont un peu
comme la mienne il y en a qui sont allés
malheureusement un petit peu plus loin
il y a eu des crédits à la consommation
qui ont été faits il y a voilà des
jeunes filles qui lui ont qui leur ont
donné leur carte de crédit voilà il
était totalement libre avec il y a eu de
l'argent qui a été prêté
bah là maintenant voilà je vis ma vie
[Musique]
donc j'ai été gymnase de haut niveau
Belgique après j'ai fait du triathlon
j'ai fait de l'équitation j'ai fait de
la boxe thaï donc je suis assez
éclectique j'ai un style de vie vraiment
parfait quand on veut dire je sais que
je suis une source d'inspiration aussi
pour beaucoup de personnes va falloir
instaurer quelques petites règles ceux
qui veulent parler peut-être aller un
peu plus loin une belle odeur de melon
qui se dégage de ces étals
honnêtement moi j'étais limite pas trop
envie de le regarder j'ai été
agréablement surpris très très
agréablement sur je suis un peu d'accord
avec toi je trouve que c'est très très
mal ouais au départ ils ont mis ils ont
casting oui mais il faut venir le
vendredi c'est clair Koh-Lanta même
Koh-Lanta c'est le plus faible lancement
de Koh-Lanta de l'histoire
parce que c'est le mardi
exceptionnellement comme celui-ci c'est
le plus bas c'est pas dû à autre chose
que
alors il y a des scandales
ça aussi
ça c'est compliqué hein tu penses quoi
tu penses que ça joue euh ça jouait
beaucoup parce que en fait beaucoup de
scandales se sont mis il y a eu la
légende de la triche qui a été énorme ça
c'est ce qu'a fait le plus mal dans
l'histoire de ça ça les amis par terre
ça c'est clair et net c'est c'est je
pense que là lui il les a c'est c'est le
scandale qui a fait du mal ouais
donnez-moi tu penses que les gens
solidarité avec les femmes il y a
beaucoup de femmes qui doivent dire lui
il est pas question que je vois sa tête
je vois les réseaux et ça marque sa voix
je la supporte plus son comportement je
supporte plus ça a pas fait un énorme
buzz mine de rien je trouve ça a été
drôlement étouffé quand même parce que
moi je trouve c'est un gros scandale il
y a des il y a des dommages collatéraux
allez pas demander à Charlotte et à
Jean-Luc son mari dans quel état ils
sont où Jean-Luc sa femme se fait
insulter incroyable et Jean-Luc sa femme
se fait insulter dans la vie normale ça
se passe pas pareil allez demander à la
jeune fille qui est toujours en
psychiatrie là depuis Juillet et en 2017
qu'en 2018 quand j'ai refait que le
deuxième Koh-Lanta c'était plus du tout
le même personnage il avait pris il
s'était étouffé il a évolué on a vu son
évolution en tant qu'animateur il prend
beaucoup de place et là ça reste que mon
mon que ma vision il a pété les boulons
en 2018 il avait déjà pété les boulons
la tête elle est devenue comme ça la
première fois qu'on a parlé de ça
c'était lors de la viande du
documentaire de Marie bortolano c'est la
première fois qu'on a un peu évoqué ça
mais de très très loin sans citer sans
citer Charlotte
de passer ton temps
entre anciens candidats de Koh-Lanta
donc c'est compliqué Pascal c'est
qu'effectivement il y a un vrai problème
Denis Brogniart il y a un tel problème
de libre rogniart que si le programme
est un peu usé du côté de la production
selon mes infos on considère que c'est
quand même beaucoup de sa faute pour la
première fois on évoque peut-être un
changement de présentateur de Koh-Lanta
et il y a un nom qui a circulé bouder
qui a d'ailleurs un peu le même profil
que Denis Brogniart parce que c'est un
journaliste qui
présente qui était à Canal+ qui est
passé Grégoire Margoton voilà selon mes
infos Grégoire Margotton pour être le
successeur de leur libre-arnia si
j'avais à choisir un successeur de Denis
Brogniart ce serait Grégoire Margotton
[Musique]
cet enseignant donc poignardé par un
élève n'a pas survécu assez blessures la
professeur d'espagnol a été attaquée en
plein cours par l'un de ses élèves âgés
de 16 ans la professeur s'appelle madame
Lassalle elle a une cinquantaine
d'années elle est globalement assez
appréciée par les élèves elle est plutôt
charismatique dynamique et elle est
depuis longtemps dans cette école qui
est très bien réputé sur la côte masque
avec aucun problème particulier ni de
délinquance ni de stupéfiants dans la
salle de classe ce qu'on nous rapporte
c'est que c'est la stupé la stupéfaction
tout le monde est sidéré certains élèves
ont peut-être même pas vu ce qui s'était
passé parce que ça se passe assez
rapidement finalement
et puis tout d'un coup la panique décrit
et la professeur surtout qui agonise
puisque elle a été mortellement touchée
d'ailleurs elle va décéder dans l'heure
qui suit d'un arrêt cardio respiratoire
cet élève est heureusement désarmé et
maîtrisé par un professeur dans une
autre salle de classe la police se rend
rapidement sur les lieux il y avait une
patrouille de police secours
heureusement qui était pas très loin on
a encore assez peu de choses on connaît
son âge on sait qu'il a 16 ans qu'il est
inconnu des services de police qu'il
avait pas de problème particulier
disciplinaires dans l'école il a dit je
suis possédé et j'ai rêvé il a dit qu'il
avait rêvé la nuit précédente enfin il
avait entendu une voix pardon qui lui
avait dit de tuer sa professeur
d'espagnol ce qu'on peut voilà c'est
quoi c'est de la schizophrénie c'est
quoi c'est ma première pensée pas la
famille de la victime bien évidemment et
puis à tous les adolescents qui ont
assisté à ce drame effroyable alors et
c'est évidemment une bouffée délirante
qui serait peut-être la porte d'entrée
dans une schizophrénie qui n'a pas
encore été décompensé puisque en général
est-ce qu'ils ont une pathologie
psychiatrique qu'on des compense à peu
près entre 17 et 20 ans il y a une autre
hypothèse qui est possible
c'est celle d'un trouble dissociatif
ça a été un choc parce que nous à
Saint-Jean-de-Luz à saint Thomas on
n'avait jamais eu de choses comme ça qui
s'était passé on n'a jamais vécu
d'événements comme ça et donc moi je
l'ai appris par l'intermédiaire de mon
frère qui était en cours moi pendant mes
années j'ai fait collège il sait là-bas
on n'a jamais eu aucun événement de ce
style tout allait bien enfin les profs
étaient sympathiques leur but est de
nous emmener vers le haut de nous faire
réussir donc on n'a jamais eu de gros
problèmes avec eux ou ça lycée cadeau
très chic là-bas
et soit on pense forcément à cette
professeur et à ses proches
quand même
qu'on doit prendre du temps avant de
pouvoir comprendre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]